bill it's day one of a new shoot and
it's an hour before you have to be on
set what are you doing hmm rejoicing
because in a business with a 98%
unemployment rate I'm about to work and
this is the happiest time because then
you can leave behind all the marketing
all the business all of the other stuff
we've discussed because none of it
really matters once you on set then
you're an artist then your passion can
can flare I go off the grid for shoots
now I started doing this after movie cut
children of sorrow it was the first time
I went off the grid the results were
good and now cell phone off computer off
I don't talk if I'm on set I'm on set
I'm on set I'm on set that's it that's
the only answer I can give to any
question the world just explode set man
I'm sorry I'll deal with in a minute all
right and unless it's you know you have
your kids in trouble or something like
that if it's an extreme emergency away
from the world and that hour before you
actually have to leave the house to go
there and leave early do something that
you love do something you really really
love what is it that you love doing more
than anything in the world I like doing
push-ups I love it I really love the
feel of it and then I love the and then
trying to do some more so I might spend
the hour listening to music I really
like or doing push-ups you know um
do something you really really like
because when you get on set you don't
want to be technical minded or business
minded you want to be in touch with your
passion and the reason that you go to
all this trouble to do it let's take it
a step further how about a few days
before you're supposed to be on set or
any things you're doing differently yes
a few days before you be on set every
single day work your lines I'm a big
believer and I got this from Michael
Caine was the best five bucks I ever
spent was Michael Caine's book acting on
film people should buy it he said work
your lines so completely that anyone
could throw you a cue at any point in
the day and you hit them back with the
cue so that there's absolutely no
thought and I do this by writing them
out in longhand and then seeing if I can
write them backwards and so every
morning for a few days before I'll go
through this exercise of writing out
and then seen if I can write them
backwards then you truly do know in
front was backwards and then all
throughout the day I'm thinking I'm
thinking I'm thinking I'm working I'm
working I'm working a market and you a
little bits of business start to come to
you that would not if you didn't have
those extra days to do it don't wait
till the day of because by that time you
should already you know have some
choices prepared and if the director
wants something different you have maybe
something else in your pocket
you